if I was a real Genie or real [ __ ]
Yoda and I thought I was like yo check
this out watch it and you saw you you
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
and we shown you and it's like a good
life and I'm like search all you got to
do you got to work 15 hours a day right
now for next 10 years right you'll do it
everybody will do it people don't do it
because they're not sure what's on the
other side of it
because they said no before they said
yes you ain't gotta be up in the office
do rabbit rabbit wolf attack wobbly talk
about ownership and leverage to a period
sectors that out of there's a virgin
because you know 2019 Amazon Alexa is
going to be in like four different car
makers default in the car so it's
literally 2018 Tesla Ford but to others
literally it's in the car and it's just
it's a time saver it's cuber uber got
real big because it saves and sells time
soundboys sells time election skill sell
time podcast fell time like and so we
really wanted that on it I want to make
sure everybody here in all their
disciplines helmet because listening is
a passive behavior that elapsed so you
can listen and go through your email you
can't watch my video and go through your
email got it and we are now and we are
now getting trained to be able to multi
consume so we're watching TV and on our
phone like we're in multi consumption
zone our brains are getting behavioral
so download into shows it just it just
you can my problems a lot of the video
problems with stuff when you're
digesting is you don't have signal of
like podcast people are downloading
previously they have yet it's also
easier to listen to a podcast while
you're working out then watch a video
when you're looking out like it's just
it's saving time I think the open white
space cuz I'm really paying attention is
multiple guests at the same time uh-huh
so I think the big white space is two
guests with you that yin and yang that
cookie that word yeah - no - gasps yeah
there's a lot of - hosts there's a lot
of - hosts that's classic like in the
mad dog like that's been around - guests
at the same time back to Jon Favreau's
dinner with for you know like there's a
dynamic when you get multiple I'm a
little worried about a third guest cuz
you crossing wires
I do think - is very and that is
something nobody's doing and I think
that can be the breakthrough and I think
that looks like you get you know the you
get the this fad you get the fancy
fashion designer and then you get the
Brooklyn fashion designer or you get the
a-list celebrity and you get the
influencer or you
the you know just like you know I don't
I'm very very very comfortable being on
the offense to me it's like this you how
I think about Jeff is this I think of it
as somebody's going to get an Easter Egg
somebody's going to read this and
realize what got stuck so to me London
LA SMB that's house here
so whatever the proper is like New York
media business we need to make sure
which is like like this eighty needs to
run on its profit yeah and then we make
these bets because our up side grows
from Africa got it that's how I think
about it that's the framework I think
under well hey Rancho hello buddies
immediately nice a donor real good real
pleasure Jeff yeah continued success
we'll be in touch
send me back Darryl hey Mike hey Colin
Howard place your towers good ok yeah
like in here ah yeah so you know Mike
obviously I'd love to answer any
questions I think we've had a basic
framework of what we're thinking about
here but I wanted to answer anything for
you and Tyler that I could to continue
moving the ball Foer Tyler the real
reason is I want to make the investment
that you're making worthwhile and I feel
like if there's more than four people
I'm diluting it you know that's why I
never want to build this model like like
I only want to sell things I believe it
video chill down for one second hi
my name is Amber Thank You amber hi
squawk - Chris oh my god s Gary Gary how
are you I'm great
can we sell short oh my god oh my I'm
sorry I'm like no worries so taken up
right now thank you nice to meet you
thank you thank you thank you Mike
I'm running late to this thing right now
I can get back on the phone with you
guys or you can email me this but can
Siri I want to over-deliver so why don't
you guys get all the apps for let me see
what I can get Gary this is Jason fell
we're fine here pleasure yeah awesome
fire Jason come man could see it's such
a pleasure yeah that's our dance like
thrilled to beat it well to be there are
you like it well yeah actually I love it
it's a quiet easy that's actually I get
it yeah I get it
all right here well you want let's just
this is box that has it that you know
then have the first time this is the
first time I've ever actually had
someone come into the magazine to get
their copies of it I love it I like I
like doing first-time things yeah that's
right he's awesome man runs on hey very
nice to meet you agree to me well hi how
are you hey everyone Gary Vee hey guys
thank you for making me look so good I
appreciate it hi hi animation thank you
pure hi
good to see you how are you good to see
you make it dance yeah thanks for coming
guys how are you thanks for having me I
don't know if you want it but this is
the smile take a concave oh okay first
off the you know when I'll definitely
take yeah yeah yeah okay when you know
when they come first off they send us
like three or four of those I love that
I hung on to us I love it weird to look
at your face on every magazine it's
super fun like honestly you know I mean
to me it's I mean it would be I'd be
lying if I didn't say it's later yeah
just let hang out but it's a super kind
of like dream come true for an
entrepreneur to be on the cover
entrepreneur you know like it's super
super fun like I'm super pumped about it
yeah like I can't wait to get texts from
like or emails and Facebook messages
from like high school friends totally
you know you know what's funny this is
actually probably a real
good month to be on the cover of
magazine because so many people travel
for more than weekend right so like the
airport action is real like that's where
I got that's where people see [ __ ] when
they don't normally see it so I was like
yeah this is probably good yeah you know
that's really interesting I mean I like
literally was like oh I hope your lies
issues like slow down by accident so I
can catch fourth of July - I was like
getting real evil like yeah my I yeah
our July August issue is combined so is
that right we push it out late yeah did
you just literally made my like
literally but I was like what an amazing
date some weird thing happened for oh we
have a July oh yeah I am here with Gary
Vaynerchuk the cover man for the 100
brilliant ideas issue and then also you
know digitally the word idea is so huge
for us because those stories that say
you know you need an idea here at um
here at under 5 your ways to find ideas
those things always do see really well
for us by the way I should introduce
myself
I'm Jason 5 from the editor-in-chief of
under order magazine and I'm again here
with Gary Vaynerchuk Gary let's talk
about ideas sure I wanted you on this
cover because you are so full of them I
think that you also inspire people to
have ideas but I think the big question
for a lot of people is if they've got
the energy they've got the drive they
know they can put in the work but they
don't have the idea to focus all of that
you know they don't have the business
yeah yeah where do the ideas come from I
think the best way to come up with an
idea is to reverse engineer what your
day to day looks like I actually think
the ideas are directly in front of your
face I think the biggest problem with a
lot of entrepreneurs is they're so
hungry to build a business or to be an
entrepreneur that they're sitting around
trying to come up with the idea which
then immediately takes you out of
usually the best idea the best idea is
I'll never forget it when Garrett camp
talked about uber he'd be like he
literally said like hey we have iPhones
now wouldn't it be cool to get a limo by
pressing a button and of course I
remember saying like that's only for
rich people wrong but I think the ideas
are to me the number one idea on earth
is scratching your own itch like if
you're living your life
and you say that sucked well you've got
a business because we really value time
we value convenience and so I would walk
around life judge what stinks and see if
there's a way to make it better and then
hopefully you're not an anomaly and the
only one that thinks it stinks yeah and
then that's to me that how you the idea
comes to you not you go and say today
I'm going to come up with nobody does
that
people do it from an intuition then it
evolved yeah but how do you test it out
right because by doing by doing I don't
know but let's stay here yeah I doing
like everybody thinks that they have to
like manifest this idea over time and
come up with is it perfect and then you
go ideas evolve I get a seed Microsoft
was in what Microsoft was Facebook is
being remotely close to what Facebook
like you've got to start with something
the biggest thing that's crippling
entrepreneurs from winning is their lack
of doing if they hold on too long a
hundred percent they they romanticize
around the idea they think they've got
an idea and then they spend the rest of
this summer debating it until there's
seven months later and I haven't done
anything and that just uses this energy
for me I appreciate you saying I have a
lot of good ideas I have a good track
record because the second I think I've
got something I go I go yeah and I lose
money and I don't lose money and I try
and I taste and I adjust I stop
I'm not scared if somebody says that
didn't work yeah yeah my dad used to
yell at me he was like you always change
your mind you said last year that we
would never sell Rose a wine I'm like I
changed my mind
mmm and it's okay to change your mind
it's okay no no we hate hockey it's the
cost of entry to be an entrepreneur yeah
I always tell my team at the agency you
know what's subjective creative creative
subjective before it hits the world then
it plays out I go you know what's not
creative deadlines it's usually
subjective you know what's not
subjective deadlines like if the client
wants it on Tuesday
you better put something in front of
them if you come on Thursday because you
guys all debated it to be perfect and
then you put it in front of somebody and
they don't like it then you've lost
twice
I think I think that's right I'm
thrilled to hear that you guys deploy
that speed and I think the necessity of
deadlines and small team is a huge
advantage and you should always take if
you listen if you're David play David's
game if you're Goliath play Goliath game
and I think for all the entrepreneurs
that are watching right now play To Your
Strengths yeah last question then yeah
I'll let you go go on with the day how
do you know as you said the key to the
key to knowing the idea is good is doing
how do you know when to stop
how do you know when to move to the next
idea if it's not working there's only
two things the market tells you where
you tell yourself right like you move on
when nobody's buying your [ __ ] like I
but I knew this was going to work and
nobody's buying it the market told you
to move on I really think you're gonna
buy this and they start buying it and
you're doing great but somehow you're
waking up miserable every day it's time
to move on
so no golden handcuffs right don't let
the dollar amount get you to a place for
thirty years later you look back you
might have made some money but you were
miserable for 30 years yeah the other
ones very easy the market tells you to
move on so the only decision you have to
make is if it's going well are you
enjoying it enough for the financial
benefit and if you're not you have to
move on yeah yeah Gary man thanks
thrilled thank you so much I'm very very
very humbled thank you thank you and I
like you're about to run out yes we take
a plea of course course no course yeah
sure sure here we go are you kidding a
puzzle
in terms of a 2010 once again that means
you can tell them never really outside
like a stunning amount considering I'm
not outside a lot you know I'm like a
regular day yeah it's really not like a
day when you're not in airport yeah I
have a little bit was 42 never I'll
never have never for dad died it's
changed flattering I can't I can't look
at it any other way
right I love interacting with people and
I'm thankful for that I always enjoyed
it so it's me it's been a really easy
transition you know I was really posting
anything or I saw you talk about or the
seventies no challenge yet and that's
what I do I sell on Amazon it yeah
before it's the last five years yeah the
thought is interesting energy was going
on and I saw there was no big seller no
one really had to use an Amazon teller a
big seller really had a big social
presence yes and I when you start
talking around with that and there was a
video that you were talking about don't
create content and I'm not don't talk
about to stop yeah that you're doing it
yet I started doing that in January
that's been awesome ever since it's the
game right yeah those of us who are
following the last couple months which
makes them buy your shed which they're
there right well I'm not like promoting
know it happened we're going to happen
it happens through osmosis and you've
got connected with others and stuff like
that right yeah
yes they mountain or Valley died of the
day
sorry I'm late on the call over to
Norfolk attention a lot of the Econo so
they can I apologize
[Music]
good guy I'm cover magazine Pacific and
then me Sean Brandon re Sean's dinner
Boehner five years now he's going to
travel the world for a year or so or
time he's going to be in Italy in late
August through October he kind of I
think potentially wants to work a
harvest or like you want to set up you
want to be you want a room potentially
for like ten weeks in Italy do you know
what part I'd love to this is where I
would actually get on the phone like
this is nothing normal should I send you
where like it'd be okay this has to
happen so get that call Harmons Carnac
and like talk to mark de Grazia
or like I don't know who you want to go
I mean I know what you know what to do
get him set up like really proper like
instead of like the like I know how we
do it so like instead of the first
option like I'll say god I've got this
accomplished I can move on get like two
options and if one's like a castle and
one's like a basement I want to have a
castle right it's going to what and much
easier to get Italian girls with a
castle than a basement I mean that good
face and all but the castle will help it
hey baby I got a cat's house right thank
you right like 350 [ __ ] friends we go
to this place think about that right
like I wrote a thank-you letter but like
you don't reach it don't like it'll be
out there but I wanted to tell you
straight up right because it's been five
plus years I was a coulis and like it's
not just I'm going
really good at social media or digital
media I don't have cell photographers
right I learned how to like like you
guys saw indicia that I didn't really
even know is there you gave me the shot
you do that you need an opportunity and
then you let me do it again and again
and again six jobs in five years in
three cities that's great
Gaston is all into the same logo I just
thank you you're welcome brother listen
this is a this is a little reprieve in
our in our game but I'm you're in my
world for life I feel it even as you sit
here I'm like I'll [ __ ] wait a minute
that energy so good like go do this real
quick like it's all good stuff man yeah
the last day when we were in the cab and
you baby like kiss me here yeah where we
almost made out exactly here woke up and
I woke up to like snapchat serrated you
all say but just like a look behind me
and they literally snapchatted that
random thing put a hearts all over it
and they were like match made in social
media heaven just random people right
like yeah and my handle wasn't even in
the episode so I don't even know how
they got it perfect but of course like
yeah they should somehow found me and
decided it snapped me in the next
morning I was like okay cool
I need to show this to him before I can
do yeah that is the best right I just
say senator I love you so much nice I'm
here every day every day and you bet
really gonna miss you
but in dude ways I feel like I'll end up
seeing you more I'm going to see you
everywhere I travel I didn't like yeah
why you're sad I love you me other good
luck
pick me up tini me yeah alright how are
you sir my dilemma hey how are you nice
to meet you how are you good to see you
I was just telling these guys I travel
although I do recruiting did my you
can't make that there was I Walter so
[ __ ] real you know it just about it
you've done a lot but I'm a recruiting
side
that [ __ ] is gold I agree my man I
appreciate that you got a nose honey big
coffee yeah boy yep it's either you get
in and we clear how quickly I get out
yeah there there are I don't think I've
ever seen a resume we're doing searches
up here
for these young Millennials that replace
anyone has ever had
you know banner anything on there which
is pretty intact it used to it easily
really it seems like obviously now as a
teenager person company you're going to
have some level of navigation got it but
I would be like in 2013 like with I mean
we don't use people we all want to write
even now we're struggling to lose people
we don't want to be like even you know
what's so weird literally right now
Shaun Cleo in our last combination here
for five years
I mean oh yeah but you could tell like
it's forever oh you know I got rolling
to another companies traveling the world
for a year right yeah and I don't eat
okay job so I mean the amount of people
that go to another agency for a non
aggression and I don't say that come in
and make you I mean like I go everywhere
you know whether I'm talking of
recruiting this [ __ ] just the I I look
at eyeballs you can tell its own just
they're taking a check out the energy is
appreciated thank you we're the right
people to follow I guess that's why I
mean I don't answer an ad like that like
Oh II okay I like doing when I saw this
drop the mag I watch the videos I love
all that [ __ ] or what I saw the bend up
like the moments right everything yeah
did you feel the same way by the way how
many of these means being I set up for
you this is the second I think second
well yeah I mean thousands yeah where
may kill pleasure mate you so pleasure
good luck to ya I'm sure I'll see you
soon hey man good to see ya oh yeah how
you settling in glass first week second
week now oh well oh well man good man
yeah let's sit down - okay
sobbing so our Alex a pleasure man how
you doing good how's it going so far
great enjoying it yeah during a lot good
man what are you German on now
um I just made just put together like
the list of college players from the
area or just like I guess it was just
being just beginning otherwise yep
yeah I love it man looking forward to
spending some time yeah thanks come say
hey by the way did you guys hear that
Justin thought he was going to be me and
happy I'll be watching play every day
for like two weeks
Justin maybe oh yeah to be honest I
actually do I actually thought he was
playing well you know and I say you were
playing well overall three laws that is
like I'm like all-time so I wanted to
get everybody together because I wanted
to kind of make sure our tech lead John
and your tech lead Wes and then all the
business people here we're lined I want
to kind of cross every T and data VI the
ambition for me is and John will have to
talk Danny's family so and which then
makes like this is all family like I you
know me we've always built things back
in 1996 we built things because I hated
being at the mercy of other things the
only thing that we're at the mercy of is
our POS system and we hate it with all
our heart right like this is the thing
right however my dream would be to hack
the natural product to be a version of
our club card that we've been chasing
for years John K I've got design
capabilities here for you if you need
them let's move tell me what you need
some a URL to scanners already does okay
we talked about the API a little bit
yeah you and Wes nerd it up and uh but
let's go full full steam ahead
great yeah okay god I don't have your
email on this I'm gonna go up something
I mean what you can notice a where the
view yeah no problem I'm looking forward
to it yeah all right off and such a
pleasure thanks for having us
you throw the beer what's up what's up
hi guys doing we're thrilled to be here
and thanks so much for joining us like
oh uh you [ __ ] hack me bro I run a
fashion question if I paint for the bus
like I know schools are [ __ ] up so
they can't take advantage but if I pay
for the bus can you bring like eight or
nine of them up here and hang with me
for an hour I couldn't wait for this day
to happen so I'm really happy you're
here
listen I'll be honest like I can give
you guys a little context I don't you
guys have any idea who I am or anything
about me okay great so to be real honest
I'd love to maximize our time together
answer [ __ ] for you maybe I'll maybe
I'll talk a little bit just to create
some framework right but to me I'd love
to just answer any questions you guys
might have or things that nature here's
my perspective my big thing you know
what caught my attention about you
talking about which is I'm fascinated by
the game of opportunity right like I
think when you get in these
conversations like who's got
opportunities reborn who wins the
lottery of being born into a trust fund
who doesn't you know who grows up in a
bad neighborhood who goes up there's
people that live in the in the in the
Amazon like literally there's so there's
a lot going on with the 7 point 7
billion people on earth to me the game
of opportunity is what's super
fascinating and I think the internet
just [ __ ] everything up in the best
way possible like there's just so much
more opportunity than there ever was for
the people that don't have the
opportunity and to me that's like [ __ ]
that's something you need to really wrap
your head around and I say that to
people that have everything handed to
them and people that have nothing handed
to them we talk a lot about don't wear
knit and knowing yourself what does that
mean
or young people that have had a hard
life or deal with a lot of different
interests kind of kids shouldn't deal
with at this age so I know somewhere has
been like knowing yourself but how do
you like what are your thoughts when
you're trying to figure out yourself and
you have to kind of deal with the
baggage in your life like you know I
never hear you talk about counseling or
anything like that sometimes wondering
like get your thoughts on more about
self-awareness or these guys look I
think people that are growing up in the
best environments of all time are
struggling with self-awareness at 13 and
14
I mean 90% 90% of my company here in
their 30s and 40s and 20s have no clue
on self-awareness so here's what I would
say I would say that I'm a big fan of
just eating reality I'm just a fan of it
you know like like the reality was I was
never like my dad my dad I had my dad
but I didn't because he worked every
hour never call the febri game has
started just insane what Debbie our that
was my rap now I was happy it was way
better any leaving or dying or you know
it was great but like I didn't have them
I could have done with my other friends
who have workaholic parents doing
dwelled like my dad's not in my baseball
game or you don't look I am NOT going to
shortchange the extremities of all the
things you know all the cliches parents
drugs murder mental health like all the
things the thing that I have not figured
out is how to get the universe to give a
[ __ ]
so so to answer your question it's
amazing to see people in good situations
and bad situations go through a
situation and do this like if I could
give everybody a drug it would be
optimism right like if you're willing to
look at all your [ __ ]
whatever it is everyone by the way
everybody thinks their [ __ ] is the [ __ ]
right like everybody's like everyone
like I've had people sit in this room
one by one with me saying well if my dad
didn't give me a hundred million dollars
I would have never been a loser because
it all came to easy to me everybody
thinks their [ __ ] the [ __ ] because it's
their life right people that don't have
parents are they laugh at that - like
[ __ ] you
but that person thinks that's the [ __ ]
so it's about you know I don't know we I
don't talk about a lot of things I don't
know I don't know how to recommend you
know you know counseling or how to build
self-awareness or mental health I try to
stay away from things that I don't know
because I think that'd be detrimental to
the things I do now what I will say is
you know self-aware so I don't know how
to teach self-awareness I just know it's
the most I just know it's the game once
you know who you are it manifests into
self-esteem you don't actually then give
a [ __ ] what you sit here and just don't
give a [ __ ] what they say or any girls
that like you just don't care it's crazy
when you get there that's like the
[ __ ] ultimate you're just [ __ ]
living life like in the matrix you're
just like runnin through shitty to
actually not give up especially at this
age that's what happened to me I still
think about it how [ __ ] did I not give a
[ __ ] right because it's like Lygon when
you're like 13 14 15 like your friend
that's your whole life I just remember
not caring and I just I was just on some
different [ __ ] in my head so that's what
I want for everybody because then you're
[ __ ] set I don't know man that's why
I don't talk that's why I don't talk
about it right like I just honestly I
swear to God
if I knew how to get there this whole
thing would be a wrap I don't know Jeff
I don't the world if I knew how to like
get there and get people there right I
try to get there by talking about it and
maybe somebody's like oh [ __ ] that's
kind of like me too
let me go deeper into that I actually do
feel like that actually don't give a
[ __ ]
like I don't know but god it's big
because then peer pressure's out then
you're just not getting dragged into
anything you don't want to be doing all
right so you know how you you know you
boast about having all the technology
and everything so I'm saying now we'll
have to do things that you know pretend
I had like do drugs or like go out there
and do whatever because we've got so
much of this we can make a board you can
make more money doing you know flipping
staple stuff and just email or not yeah
so like so he would just take anything
that's like it's going to take like
maybe a hundred pounds teach you how to
get it sooner or later my belief is that
if you're a great drug dealer you'd be a
great businessman I just believe that
because it's the same game you're
selling your work in it like like listen
that's the only friends I have we're
drug dealer like like like if you're
good at that I'm saying you know there's
a lot of drug dealers that suck at it
right like like right right right like
listen I made like all the kids that I
really hung on to and friendships I'm
like look at me he's breaking down these
bags and some nickels because he's
making more money that way and he's
chanting he's actually making $3 bags
but he realized that everybody at the
school doesn't know the [ __ ]
difference doesn't care he's smart and I
would see other people who like by like
an ounce and I [ __ ] smoked
three-fourths of it in four minutes and
then like be bad at flipping it I was
like he's a [ __ ] loser so if you're
good at it or if somebody if somebody's
good at it they'd be even better at
flipping sneakers or gear or go into the
thrift store and flipping because it's
the same [ __ ] move and then when you
have the freedom of being not scared to
get caught now you're [ __ ] moving
fast because when you're selling drugs
you got to think about that extra
dimension of getting caught but when
you're selling [ __ ] t-shirts now
you're a [ __ ] entrepreneur and
everybody thinks you know like people
put you on a pedestal
so yes I believe that I love them
I believe it because it's true because
it's [ __ ] true because the kids that
I knew that sold drugs for real and
we're real good at it have gone on to be
much more successful in the world than
the ones that did it like it's just
hustle if you've got people skills
you see angles that's the same [ __ ]
that's like [ __ ] this thrift store keeps
getting their [ __ ] merchandise and
they put it out at 9:30 in the morning
I'm gonna go there because there might
be some Nikes but it's just hard work
but I think every like when you realize
how much more money you can make how
much like how much good can happen from
hard work everybody's willing to put in
the hook if I pry if I was a real genie
or a real [ __ ] Yoda and I thought I
was like yo check this out watch it and
you saw you your luck with the fluff and
you saw you and it's like a good life
and I'm like - all you got to do you got
to work 15 hours a day right now for the
next 10 years right you'll do it
everybody will do it people don't do it
because they're not sure what's on the
other side of it because they said no
before they said yes my big thing is
like you're going to you're going to
define yourself for yourself or you
going to let somebody else to find you
you're going like your mom to find you
your dad to find your grandparents to
find your older brother your older
sister dude from around the way
you know you somebody's going to define
you or you're going to define yourself
I'm just trying to figure out how to
hack at you to make you define yourself
for yourself in yourself within yourself
and then then should change us yeah you
got this I like you people can choose
oh my god I love this and just the same
thanks I appreciate it late comment
look yeah yeah of course my mom I'll do
better than that you know what let come
with me in my office I'll let them sign
up I'll sign you guys all a book
thank you love it my right ready guy
we're good one two three I'm telling you
my man when I told you the truth
listen truth crazy it's just real I know
it's all real it's just real you know
you know it's better if I'm making
eighteen dollars a day selling chakras
versus making 100 it's hard at first but
you just [ __ ] hold your breath you
can get there faster though everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 254 of the askgaryvee show and
this is a very very very special episode
because the all-time most popular guest
of my original video and podcast show
back in the day Wine Library TV was none
other than my dad Sasha Vaynerchuk who
is here looking dapper dad sort of a
deuce I like that and and who is now
making his second appearance of the
askgaryvee show
we got variable yeah we remember we got
emotional up in the or Andy was there we
were playing basketball we have this
great episode oh yeah what else is some
numbers that anybody this guy's on it
he saw Andy's very impressive tennis oh
yeah it's a real good one you should ask
him the vodka sparkly ticker symbols
everyone else IRA not a story anyone
knows so in Boston my junior year on
Comm Ave there was nowhere to really
really Park so it was super hard so I
just would park in places I ended up
with like six what do you think forty
guys he's what is a glove garment when
you open all the parking tickets well
I've got to build 100
yes cooking with EMI and heat she came
to me and being a top father you know
what everybody say I hate all the things
yeah you're only top on the outside
right
super soft loud babe over there that's
right like the iris and what about the
$10,000 applause you know we're not
going into that story
we've got George that story's not coming
out sad stories Emily I'll cut it out
how's a person success and he came to
questions report that gets through out
of control I love you dad thank you
you can keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]
we're here with the the opposite CEO
we're meeting with Gary basically to
give him updates on projects that were
working on catch up on things on his end
see if there's anything that he needs us
to do
he's traveling a lot over the next
couple a couple months so we've been
chatting with some ambassadors building
a cadence so that whether he's here
we're meeting with him in person or
whether we're just setting up phone
calls that we just set some degree of a
cadence on I'm keeping in touch so we
can make sure we don't lose any momentum
I hate him with all my heart but I'm
Michael Jordan and you should let
Michael Jordan take the last shot in the
game and it's been the biggest iOpener
for me which is I am such not a
micromanager I want to let everybody
know what what manifests from that is it
gets away from me if you don't get it to
the email this kid you want me to meet
like oh we need everybody if everybody
knew who I was we'd be rolling if they
really knew and I think we have to be
smart about scaling me so that's what I
would shout
always think about what that means
whatever the [ __ ] that means whether
that means you scaling me whether that
means you being like you debate
defending me whether you tell me I
should get this I mean this has been
great this matters give me one second so
I can look at how behind I am and what I
have next and then we'll take it in this
everyone doing all right here
this was not a joke
in 2007 me and AJ are up at like 4
o'clock in the morning building like
some cockamamie on website and my
brother my brother looked at me and said
bro you can tell me like I won't tell
anyone you're my brother I love you
are you robot are you know but it seems
like I won't tell the authorities like
you don't pee drink eat and you're on
24/7 365 straight cool thank you guys so
much for coming out guys enjoyed it fun
right I'm a huge fan I think I think I
actually now believe as I continue to
homework that the convergence of VR and
AR it's actually what happens in reality
yeah I'm a you believe in it makes
reality artificial intelligence I don't
think people understand how all this
occur after one technology it supposed
to go understand how Tech Talks each
other right they don't understand API in
a can or span they understand the scaled
mortification of our society they don't
understand they understand that like a
week after I started using Alexa I
started using hearing where was eyes
like you and I use is untimely
that's that that's for 360 regular hit
that's where I matured in the last 25
years
1994 Gary Vee would have been like oh my
god this is next week tomorrow I did I
launched an e-commerce wine business in
1996 because by the year of 1998
everybody's going to buy wine on the
Internet
I learned this backing so pleasure yeah
thank you so much so my Center yeah hey
guys all right nice niche you my idea I
am Gary at vaynermedia we do that's what
we do for a living yeah we go through
this like we're trying to develop it
Tamagotchi digital pet you've already
got my attention though we're gonna love
you coming up I'm Lewbert
you've got my attention cool off of your
take Eric
10:43 I'm wrapping up I'm going to an
HBO event that they're not letting
Justin in Justin if you enjoy the day
get that yeah you get to go home
bubble-hockey you lost 4-1
yeah those tough loss for you and I'll
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you
[Music]